Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to the Try Not To Laugh Challenge™!
And, SURPRISE SURPRISE!
I'm not dead.
Uh, I was working on a very personal project...
Uh, that you guys are gonna see TOMORROW,
but it was one of those things that took longer than expected because...
It was one of those things that just takes as long as it needs to...
and, uh it's not really dependent on what's going on.
But, I went in a cave, I turned off my phone,
I didn't see anything,
so, for all I know, the world has exploded.
*Chuckling* And I have no idea anymore.
But!
It's time to... laugh away my miseries, at the end of the world...
with some "HILARIOUS" videos
of which I'm going to "LAUGH at very HARDLY"...
and tha- I mean "HARDLY LAUGH at!"
That's what I meant... That's what I meant...
*Mario Theme song*
*Gunshot*
*Mario theme song continues, slightly awry*
*BANG*
*Theme song continues, once more off-kilter*
*little better this time*
*BANG BANG BANG*
*Only 2 notes wrong here*
*bang*
*Mario Game Over music with gunshots too*
*Mario Game Over Theme with gunshots too*
*Final BANGs*
TumpetMan: "hoo-hoooooooooo!"
Pop the TrumpetMan: Happy birthday Nate, love Mom and Pop.
What a wholesome family.
What an UNBELIEVEABLE, WHOLESOME, FAMILY!
What an adorable way to celebrate a birthday!
*Sheeps's bahing in the background*
baaAAAAAAH
Something wrong with that...
mmm-sheep...
RAM!
M-ram. Ram's the right word...
Ramrod.
*Running in the 90s slowly getting louder*
Don't like where this going.
*Music increases and fades as Naked Guy slides under door*
*Groans*
I hate nudity!
MMM- makes me grumpled.
*inhale*
M-Not FFFunny!
*beginning to Through The Fire And Flames*
*Fidget spinner plays song badly*
*Nose sounds*
I don't even...
know what...
that was.
But...
that
iS
NOT
F U N N Y !
*dial clicking*
Alright, I'm ready to be impressed.
*Marty Prepares to strum guitar*
*Sniff*
All right.
*toot*
*soft, barely audible snorts*
*constrained snicker*
*snort*
*continues to constrain his laughter*
Nope.
*Guy practicing tuba*
*Thunk*
*Screaming*
*"I Feel Good" by James Brown plays*
*Starts to break*
*Weird mouth sounds*
Smiling is not laughing!
"...home improvements yourself, mistakes happen,
For example, if you're trying to put a picture frame up there on the wall...
*SMASH*
*Stunted snorting*
*sigh* Oh, frick!
"Ya like jazz?-
"Ah, mom, why did yo-
AAAHHHH!"
"AH! You crushed HIIIIIIM,
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!-"
*Mute screaming*
Nope.
"It's a fuckin' bear-
NNNNNNOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!!!"
*Panting*
Oh shit, it's right there..."
*Guy's exhausted laugh*
*Breathes*
AHHH!
"Your girl knows I've got the sauce!
No ketchup,
Just sauce!"
"Raw sauceeee
BOOM!
YO!"
"GAH!"
"THE TING GOES SKRRAA!"
"POP POP KA KA KA!"
"SKI KI KI POP POP!"
"AND A PU PU PURRR POOM!"
"SKYAAA!"
"POO POO POO POO POO POOM!"
"POOM POOM!"
"You dun'no,
Big Shaq!"
"Ha, yo, yeah yeah-"
*Sighs in the agony of hilariousness*
*Snickers*
*Sighs*
Clever.
Not funny.
"Pea...
Ayy...
Arr...
Kay...
Kee...
Gee...
Tea!"
"Penguin!"
*Burst into silenced laughter*
Did you say "Penguin"?
*distorted version of "Who Let the Dogs Out?" plays*
*Mark laughs*
*Lady laughs as the card plays*
*Laughs*
*Silent screaming*
*HAAAA*
*Laughing* Fuck!
*song plays again*
*Laughs*
*Manly exhale*
Well, I lost.
Uh, just a few more.
*Children screaming*
Pfft!
*chimp laugh*
*Hah hah hah*
*Human laughter*
*Laughing* I just never expect them to be so quick.
'Cuz I- I hide the length of the video from me...
'cuz that way I don't know if it's gonna be a quick one!
Oh, my god!
*Silent raspy laugh*
*Laughs again*
"OOOO-"
*bursts into laughter*
I didn't know what was happening at first!
"Yes, it was.. pouring down rain on my drive to Eugene's-
[poor couch :c ]
"Oh my gosh! Riso-
"Oh you should see what Riso's doing!"
"He's so strong and fast!
"Oh my, that's more amazing than what Xavier did that time!"
*Laughs like parrot*
"Amazing."
*More laughter*
*Laughing* "He's so strong and he's so fast"...
*Seagull Evil laughs*
*Mark cackling*
*Laughing again* Me too Bird, me too.
*louder Evil cackling*
Alright...
*growls*
Welp, that's the end of the roHOad for me.
I- uh...
I made it pretty far!
In that, I made it exactly as far as I always do.
But, anyway...
That is the Try Not to Laugh challenge.
I'm probably not gonna do another one for a while.
I'm gonna stockpile more videos.
I've done a few every week, uh, for the past few weeks...
but... tomorrow is...
I- it should be ready.
I'm not gonna say what it is.
It's something that's...
I- I don't know...
It's something that I wanted to do very much, and it's turning out okay...
and...
hopefully it's not crap!
So, that's all I have to say about that.
So thank you, everybody, so much for watching.
Remember, the tour ticket sales... are still going on!
There's now a convenient... bar down there that takes you right to where the nearest show is.
It's pretty cool.
So check it out down there in the description...
and thank you, everybody, for watching.
Let me know if you won.
Let me know if you laughed.
Let me know if you didn't.
Let me know if any of these were funny at all to you.
So thanks again.
And as always, I will see you... in the next video!
Ba-BYE!